to form a CIA chief is suggesting that
NATO would have no reason to exist if it
were not for Russia David Petraeus was
speaking at a conference in India on
Wednesday Vladimir Putin is the greatest
gift to NATO since the end of the Cold
War and it has provided a new reason for
living if you will for NATO those
remarks appear to be at odds with NATO's
official view the Secretary General's
repeatedly stressed the need for better
relations with Russia NATO is goal is
not the new Cold War we strive for a
better relationship with the Russia
we're not in the old Cold War NATO
doesn't want a new Cold War but that's
the same NATO chief who's been
repeatedly warning of Moscow's
aggression and claiming that's why the
alliance holds drills near the Russian
border this is an important day because
trial juncture is NATO's biggest
exercise since the end of the Cold War
[Applause]
[Music]
the scenario is fictitious but the
lessons we learn will be real Petraeus
is expressing his determination to
continue as I read it the aggressive
expansion and aggressive posture of NATO
which began before President Putin came
on the scene we should remember that it
began in the mid 90s with the war in
Yugoslavia bombing of Yugoslavia the
expansion into every East European
country into the Baltics NATO has
expanded from its original 12 members
now to 29 and in NATO
it is really a US dominated commanded
military alliance which is trying to
enforce u.s. corporate domination on a
global scale using military threats
sanctions sabotage hundreds of US bases
around the world and it's not that
anything that Russia has done has not
expanded beyond its borders as NATO has
or anything that China has done but NATO
as an aggressive military alliance it's
expanded in a really aggressive way and
as a global military force
you